das hier ist lediglich still gehört auch
dem kundenparkplatz und ich bin
irgendwie der einzige kunde heute glaube
ich okay leute ich bin wieder da
vom aldi und ich bin wirklich nicht
geschockt aber schon heftig überrascht
also das ist so krass ist hätte ich
wirklich nicht gedacht hey was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja neulich habe mir natürlich geht
es gut vor zwei tagen kam ein wirklich
sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr interessantes
video 100 euro bei primark bis 100 euro
bei gucci wenn ihr das so nicht gesehen
habt würde ich euch schon empfehlen dass
euch anzuschauen
eine direkte frage haben sie jedenfalls
für unter 100 euro
falls ich es auch nicht schlimm dann
schaut einfach dieses hier
ich habe aber unter dem video was ich
halt am mittwoch hoch geladen habt
folgenden kommentar gelesen und da meint
irgendwer york macht es doch mal bei
edeka und aldi hat sich vielleicht erst
mal ein bisschen langweiliger an weil
ich meine das sind halt beides so
standard supermärkte ich weiß nicht die
meisten von euch sind ja auch noch ein
bisschen länger dagegen wahrscheinlich
eltern einkaufen aber ihr könnt ja gern
mal in die kommentare schreiben zu
welchem supermarkt hier geht oder wenn
ihr mal einkaufen geht wohin geht ich
schreibe es in die kommentare auf jeden
fall ist es ja kein geheimnis dass zum
beispiel aldi laut studien aussagen was
wenn sich eher so zu den günstigeren
supermärkten genau und so leben wie rewe
oder halt auch erika teurer sein soll
ich habe mehr zu sagen keine ahnung ob
das so wirklich stimmt deswegen gibt es
halt heute dieses video also machen
wollte war denn live test ich nehme euch
mit mit der kamera und wir schauen mal
was kriegen wir für 50 euro bei aldi und
was bringen diese 50 euro bei edeka und
ist dann ein großer unterschied am ende
vorhanden oder halt nicht vor ich kurz
einmal die spielregeln zu erklären damit
ihr versteht okay das ist wirklich ein
sehr interessanter test und wir haben am
ende auf jeden fall ein richtig richtig
interessantes ergebnis ich habe mir so
eine liste erstellt die blende ich euch
hier mal ein und auf dieser liste haben
wir ungefähr 20 verschiedene
lebensmittel zum beispiel in der zweiten
zeile haben wir dreimal cola und dann in
klammern marke also wir kaufen bei
beiden leben
marco lugato dann haben wir bananen das
sind halt keine marken annan und dann
steht er dreimal nur wie den günstigsten
also wir kaufen bei den günstigsten und
bei edeka den günstigsten und dann gibt
es auch noch eigenmarke wie zb bei
eistee oder kaffee da glaube ich die
eigenmarke vom supermarkt und ja dann
haben wir glaube ich am ende wirklich
gutes ergebnis ich habe im internet so
eine studie an geguckt da stand zum
beispiel dass der gleiche einkauf im
edeka 45 euro gekostet hat und im aldi
etwas mehr als 35 also wir haben das
schon unterschied also leute wir
vernetzt los einkaufen sehen uns im auto
weil ich habe mir keine dinger in der
nähe da muss ich hin fahren ich denke
ich brauche erstmal zum edeka war das
sehr teurer sein soll und dann ist
später die überraschung umso größeres
ist beim aldi viel mehr geld für viel
weniger oder halt auch nicht keine
ahnung haut rein
bis gleich ich frag mich jetzt gerade wo
ich hier gelandet bin das hier ist edeka
und ich stimme hört auf den
kundenparkplatz und ich bin irgendwie
der einzige kunde heute logisch also
dass anscheinend mega kleiner laden
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt wie teuer
ist ja so leute jetzt habe ich dort
netterweise von der mitarbeit hier so
ein chip bekommen
das habe ich nämlich schon einkaufswagen
bei den brauche ich weiß auf jeden fall
mit meinem hohen gipfel
ich glaube ich war noch nie alleine mit
seinem einkaufswagen einkaufen naja
irgendwann ist immer das erste mal so
wie jetzt habe ich schon mal hier drei
smoothies dass man die günstigsten für
einen euro 59
also das ist auf jeden fall schon mal
viel aber ist also leute hier mal den
kaffee eigenmarke den brauche ich auch
auf jeden fall
ich habe jetzt schon noch bananen den
eistee eigenmarke und 43 colaflaschen
leute haben wir auf jeden fall die
pizzen
ich nehme hier jetzt mal zwei mit auf
jeden fall marke und dass wir gleich
auch die gleiche marke haben also dann
halt im boden schützen sind auch drin
und hier sogar ein angebot 65 weiße
schokolade
die ist nämlich ich wollte eigentlich
ritter sport aber die haben die hier
nicht deswegen gehen wir einfach zweimal
make-up heute denkt übrigens nicht dass
ich
total ungesund einkaufe es geht mir nur
darum dass ich jetzt er lebensmittel
kaufen die halt länger haltbar sind
normalerweise gehe ich halt wirklich
jeden tag einkaufen ich kaufe jetzt also
auf vorrat ein und nur das was man halt
wirklich lange lagern kann weil ich
lebte allein und leute also ich muss
sagen der wagen fühlt sich auf jeden
fall kann irgendwie überhaupt nicht
einschätzen wie viel das jetzt schon ist
wollte ich bin jetzt eigentlich durch
mit meiner liste jetzt fehlt mir nur
noch nutella 2009 und also hotel und das
war's ich habe vorher mal durchgerechnet
dass sollten ungefähr 50 euro seien
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob es
deutlich mehr oder deutlich weniger ist
wir werden so leute also ich bin durch
ich habe das ganze jetzt bezahlt und ich
habe ja gerade auch gesagt ich schaue
jetzt mal ob es weniger oder mehr als 50
euro wird weil ich habe ja einfach nur
gestellt und jetzt passt nur auf wir
haben hier genau 49 eur 180 für diese
ganzen sachen also ich würde sagen
besser schätzen kann man nicht oder ich
bringe das jetzt erst mal hier in mein
auto
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich gleich aufpassen dass ich
mich durcheinander kommen obwohl leute
ich glaube ich falls kurz nach hause
lagert die ganzen sachen ab weil das
heißt und so schmilzt natürlich und wie
schon gesagt also sachen wie obst und
gemüse kaufe ich nicht weil für mich
reichen diese sachen echt extrem lange
ich denke ich stelle das meiste davon
erstmal im keller normalerweise gehe ich
halt wirklich alle zwei tage einkaufen
so viel 10 15 20 euro keine ahnung und
wenn ich jetzt mal so nachdenke
das ist heute wirklich das allererste
mal dass ich für mich selber so ein
großeinkauf mache ich habe das noch nie
gemacht auch nicht so mit seinem einkauf
sorgen und so natürlich früher mal so
mit meiner mutter aber sonst ja also ich
sag mal so ich bin auf jeden fall noch
kein experte auf diesem gebiet also wir
fahren jetzt zu aldi vielleicht eine
kurze einschätzung also ich finde viele
sachen von denen die ich jetzt verkauft
habe schon teuer deswegen bin ich mal
gespannt was wir im all jetzt haben wie
gesagt ihr 49 eur 85 edeka für diese
ganzen sachen das ganze werde ich jetzt
auch im aldi kaufen und dann schauen wir
mal wo war da und ihr sollt ihr an euren
lieblings supermarkt in die kommentare
schreiben wenn ihr sagt mach dass du
auch mal da was es da geht auf jeden
fall nach oben für das videoformat so
leid ich bin wieder zu hause ich genieße
gerade bei uns im keller weil ich eine
menge lebensmittel hatte ich alle in
unsere wohnung kriegen muss und das gute
ist ich habe irgendwann mal hier so
einen einkaufswagen auf der straße
gefunden und den haben wir irgendwie
schon stehen
doch noch irgendwie von euch eine
mikrowelle so dann mal los ich möchte
mich gleich sofort dass auf jeden fall
los also bis vielleicht leute ohne spaß
oder den einkaufswagen welche übels
aufgeschmissen bei so einem großen
einkauf also hier haben wir die ganzen
sachen vom edeka außer die sachen die
jetzt in der tiefkühltruhe sind ich muss
sagen ich finde noch so viel sieht das
gar nicht aus deswegen bin ich jetzt mal
umso mehr gespannt wie teuer diese
ganzen sachen beim aldi sind
ich habe echt hunger am liebsten wieder
etwas essen aber wir waren erst
einkaufen oder was ist er ja wieder
einkaufen hat sich schon so leute
angekommen bei aldi süd wollte ich schon
er ist mittlerweile schon bei aldi und
jetzt schauen wir mal hier vom wahlamt
ich werde es auch gar nicht mal so viel
fällen weil das ja irgendwie auch
langweilig
deswegen schlimm weil ich werde ich bin
also haben wir auf jeden fall zahnpasta
für 45 senden wird das ist wirklich das
günstigste eben hat mir 99 also wollte
ich jetzt das einzige was mir fehlt ist
leider dieser marken eistee den gibt's
hier nicht trotzdem ist das alles ich
weiß ein bisschen weniger aus aber der
einkaufswagen ist größer wir gehen als
auf jeden fall mal zur kasse
und dann will ich mal gespannt
okay leute ich bin wieder da vom aldi
und ich bin wirklich nicht geschockt
aber schon heftig überrascht also das
ist so krass ist hätte ich wirklich
nicht gedacht ich dachte da hat er ist
eigentlich kann das nicht sein irgendwas
hast du schon vergessen aber ich habe
nichts vergessen also eben hatten wir ja
914 euro 85 jetzt haben wir 33 eur 6
also einen fucking unterschied von jetzt
muss ich kurz rechnen über 16 euro wobei
ich noch sagen muss dass ich jetzt halt
nicht die ice t dosen gekauft haben weil
sie hier nicht gab können wir
meinetwegen noch mal zwei euro obendrauf
sprechen sind wir mal 35 euro das wasser
was ich hier gekauft habt ist auch kein
video wasser also keinen marken wasser
war sehr sehr günstig davon habe ich
aber doppelt so viel gekauft wie im
edeka eben einbringen kann man da auch
mal sagen ja gut rechne man noch mal 150
drauf oder euro sind wir bei 36 euro
also immer noch einen heftigen
unterschied von so um die 25 prozent
also das ist schon krass so laut ich bin
mittlerweile wieder in der wohnung
angekommen und habe ich beides mal
aufgestellt also ja hier haben wir
einmal die ganzen sachen von edeka und
hier die sachen von aldi ich muss
irgendwie sagen das sieht auch gerade
erwarte macht dieses hier
sorry so also heute würde ich so auf den
ersten blick sagen dass sie irgendwie
mehr aus ich habe keine ahnung
vielleicht liegt es auch am wasser auf
jeden fall war es auch deutlich
günstiger hier könnt ihr es vielleicht
nochmal genau sehen also hier haben wir
all die boom 33 euro und hier edeka 49
euro und ich kann euch wirklich
versichern
es sind genau gleich viele produkte
leute das hier nehme ich jetzt im
nachhinein noch auf weil mir aufgefallen
ist dass wenn ich mir jetzt schon mal
diese ganze mühe gemacht habt und da die
leben verglichen habe ich war da
einkaufen war da einkaufen dass ich mich
noch mal kurz ein bisschen damit
beschäftigen okay woran genau liegt das
jetzt beziehungsweise an welchen
produkten liegt es dass wir halt diesen
krassen preisunterschied von gut 14 euro
haben und zwar kann ich einmal sagen es
liegt an der marken pizza ja die hat im
edeka 2 eur 69 gekostet war es schon
teuer ist im all die nur 1 99
also da haben wir ja schon mal ein
unterschied von 70 cent also das finde
ich wirklich schon recht heftig keine
ahnung wie das zustande kommt aber gut
zu wissen ist übrigens keine eigenen
flächen und hier oder so
es wird halt einfach nur um fakten was
ich auch auf jeden fall sagen kann die
eigenmarken von aldi seien deutlich
günstiger
jetzt kommt die sonne raus eine sache
die mir aber auch aufgefallen ich habe
beim edeka für einen liter cola ich habe
drei liter insgesamt gekauft jeweils 1
euro 19 gezahlt plus fand im aldi
hingegen habe ich sogar 1,25 liter für
nur 99 cent kriegt losfahren also das
sind halt diese kleinen
preisunterschiede je mehr man kauft
desto größer wird die differenz ist ja
logisch und daran liegt halt das wollte
ich jetzt doch hier sagen mehr gibt es
allerdings nicht mehr zu sagen hat zum
beispiel hat bei beiden gleich gekostet
270 ja weiter geht's ich weiß nicht
vielleicht kann man sagen dass die
qualität bei edeka deutlich besser ist
und sich lohnt mehr geld dafür
auszugeben
ich finde diesen unterschied von 14 euro
oder so was da jetzt errechnet hat
trotzdem kraft hätte ich nicht gedacht
ich hatte gedacht es sind vielleicht so
irgendwas zwischen fünf und zehn maximal
schreibt sogar gerne eurem einsatz in
die kommentare ich habe also auf jeden
fall lebensmittel für die nächsten zwei
drei monate können schon obwohl das
vielleicht ein bisschen lang bei
erreicht auf jeden fall ich war auch
bestimmt brauche ich war locker jetzt
über zweieinhalb stunden einkaufen das
war's mit dem video weitere ideen für
dieses format in die kommentare
haut rein ach so und würden wir auf
install online sich alex thies super
super wichtig